IAN LAKE: Remember back when
dinosaurs ruled the earth,
and Android notifications
looked like this?
Oh my.
Thankfully, I've seen
fewer dinosaurs around.
And Android notifications
have gotten a lot better.
Ever-evolving APIs don't
always make for the easiest
development experience.
And that's why there's
NotificationCompat.
It gives you a single interface
across all API levels,
so you can concentrate
on building
the best notifications you can.
I'm Ian Lake.
And I'll show you how you can
build awesome notifications
with the help of
NotificationCompat,
helping reengage users whether
they're on their phone, watch,
or in their car.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let's start at the beginning.
Every notification has a few
required parts-- a small icon,
title, and text.
To build a notification, use
a NotificationCompat builder.
Then build and send
the notification.
Done.
One fatal flaw.
Tapping on this
notification does nothing.
Nothing!
We need a content
intent that points
to the activity we
want to launch when
the user taps the notification.
But we can do so much
more with notifications.
Set a color, to make
the notification
recognizable as from your app.
Set a large icon, and
now we actually know
who the notification is from.
Already you have something
you might actually
want to click on.
This compact title and
text format is the basic.
And all of it's available
on older platforms.
But basic shouldn't
be where you stop.
Let's make this good.
Like, really good.
On Android 4.1 and
higher devices,
notifications can
expand, giving you
more space to work with,
going beyond the title and one
line of text.
NotificationCompat
provides four styles.
Which you can use to
improve your notifications,
particularly when expanded.
You'll find BigTextStyle for
showing multiple lines of text,
such as a long message,
perfect to actually see
the full message.
InboxStyle, for showing a
list of single line strings.
BigPictureStyle
for showing a-- you
guessed it-- a big
picture when expanded.
And MediaStyle, for adding
media controls directly
to your notification.
Well, now our notification
has some room to breathe
and gives users a
lot of information,
pulling them back into your app.
Good.
But we're busy people.
Adding actions to
your notification
gives users quick access to
the most important actions,
without breaking their groove.
Not that I'd ever mute Joanna.
But notifications aren't just
on your mobile device anymore.
They're also on your
wrist, with Android Wear.
Any actions you've added
to your notification
are automatically mirrored
over to Android Wear devices,
enabling users to handle
tasks without even pulling out
their phone or opening the app.
But mirroring your phone
experience over to Android Wear
can only get you so far.
To really make things great,
you can use NotificationCompat's
WearableExtender.
Here's where all the
Wear-specific magic happens.
We've talked about
mirroring actions.
With WearableExtender,
you can build
the perfect set of actions
that makes sense for the watch.
Including voice replies.
Again, rich actions that
increase engagement, even when
the user can't open your app.
Another example is adding a
high resolution background
image, the easy way to offer
a literally crisp experience.
There's a lot more
NotificationCompat's
WearableExtender
gives you though,
including adding additional
pages of information
to the notification for
extra content and the ability
to group notifications
together into a stack,
giving you all the
details on the watch,
but a summary
notification on the phone.
OK, so there's a lot you
can do on your wrist.
What about an Android
Auto equipped car?
Here, messaging apps can
use NotificationCompat's
CarExtender to send a message,
or a whole set of messages,
in a conversation to
Android Auto, where
they can be read aloud and
the user can voice reply,
all while keeping
their eyes on the road.
So, using
NotificationCompat, you
get a single API for all
Android versions, support
for progressive
enhancements through adding
styles and actions,
and even the tools
to bring great notifications to
Android Wear and Android Auto.
That's a lot of opportunity to
make beautiful notifications
everywhere.
Get started with
NotificationCompat
by adding the support
library to your project.
You'll need App Compat for
media style notifications,
or just support
v4 for everything
else NotificationCompat
has to offer.
With the tools you need to
build great notifications
on a phone, tablet, watch, and
car, you can't help but build
better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]